رياضيوننا ومنظمات دوليه تحتج على احتمال
اعدام ايران لعب كره قدم واعتقاله ممثله
شهيره
فرز الاصوات في تونس وهيئه الانتخابات
تفسر ضعفا المشاركه بنظام الاقتراع وغياب
المال السياسي
اسدال الستار على فعاليه المونديال اليوم
بمباراه بين المنتخبين الارجنتيني
والفرنسي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشرتهم اهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمه لكم ابراهيم بدر احتجا
رياضيون ومنظمات دوليه على احتمال اعدام
اللاعب الايراني امير نصر الزاني اللاعب
السابق في فريق تراكتور لكره القدم وطالبت
الرابطه الدوليه للاعبي كره القدم
في هذه المدينه
من جهتها اعلنت منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه ان 39 متظاهرا على الاقل
يواجهون حاليا خطر الاعدام فيما حذرت
امكانيه تنفيذ اعدامات في البلاد على نطاق
واسع واشاره المنظمه الى ارتفاع عدد قتلى
الاحتجاجات على ايدي قوات الامن الى
469 شخصا منذ انطلاق مظاهرات منتصف سبتمبر
الماضي وقالت المنظمه ان عدد القتلى في
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها البلاد منذ وفاه
الشابه ماسه امينه يتضمن ثلاثه و60 طفلا
واثنتين وثلاثين امراه
اندلعت اشتباكات بين ضباط سجن كرج شمال
ايران والسجناء بعد الاعدادي لتنفيذ احكام
الاعدام بحق العشرات بتهمه الاتجار في
المخدرات حسب التلفزيون
وعلقت المعارضه مريم رجوي على احتجاجات
كرج قائله انها تاتي عقب الحكم بالاعدام
التعسفي للسجناء الذين رفعوا شعار الموت
لخامينائي واضافت بان هذا هو صوت
الايرانيين الذين يريدون انهاء النظام
الاعدام والتعذيب والارهاب والطلبه رجل
والمجتمع الدولي باتخذه اجراءات الفوريه
لوقف عمليات الاعدام في ايران
قبل ذلك اعتقلت السلطات الايرانيه الممثله
الشهيره والناشطه في مجال حقوق الانسان
ترانا علي دوسي الممثله الايرانيه البالغه
من العمر 38 عاما اعلنت عده مرات دعمها
للتظاهرات على تطبيق انستغرام وقالت وكاله
تسليم للانباء ان الممثله اعتقلت بسبب
بمزاعم تتعلق بنشر معلومات كذبه والتحريض
على الفوضى من دون اعطاء تفاصيل عن مكان
توقيفها
في غضون ذلك ذكرت وسائل الاعلام ايرانيه
ان عددا من اعضاء الطواقم الطبيه في
البلاد اعلنوا مشاركتهم في اضرابات
واحتجاجات مقرره هذا الاسبوع وقال
التقاليد صحفيه ايرانيه ان اعضاء من
الطواقم الطبيه تضامنوا مع الاضطرابات
المقرر ان تبدا الاثنين لمده ثلاثه ايام
وذلك تمديدا بقمع قوات الامن وانتهاج
النظام لسياسه الاعدامات ردا على
التظاهرات
[موسيقى]
بدات في تونس عمليته فرزي اصوات الناخبين
بعد اغلاق مراكز الاقتراع في الانتخابات
التشريعيه رئيس هيئه العليا للانتخابات
فاروق بوعسكر قال ان نتائج الاوليه
للانتخابات التشريعيه سيتم الاعلان عنها
غدا الاثنين مشيرا الى ان نسبه المشاركه
تجاوز الثمانيه بالمئه
نسب الاقبال المتواضعه نعم
ولكن ان نقول مخجله جدا
فالموضوع هذا يستحق نظر لانه اذا كان
نشوفه
في النواب الذين دخلوا البرلمان في سنه
اسباب وذلك
في اعتقادي سبب واضح
هو تغير نظام الاقتراع وانعدام المالي
السياسي في الحملات الانتخابيه
لانه اول مره وبعدين يقول لها على
مسؤوليتنا حكايه انتخابات لاول مره تصير
انتخابات انتخابيه نظيفه من المال السياسي
اللي هو كان السبب
وراء شراء الاصوات
التونسيه كانت نقيه من الاموال الاجنبيه
والاموال السياسيه
من توظيف وسائل الاعلام السياسيه
هذا هو اتصل لاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي
اعلن عنها الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد قبل
نحو عام الى الخطوه الاخيره باجراء
الانتخابات التشريعيه المبكره انتخابات
برلمانيه صاحبها الكثير من الجدل في الوقت
الذي يعول بعض عليها لحاله المازق السياسي
تصل خارطه الطريق التي اعلن عنها الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد الى محطتها الاخيره وهي
الانتخابات التشريعيه المبكره
عن اجراءاته الاستثنائيه في الخامس
والعشرين من يوليو العام الماضي تغير وجهه
تونس
كل اختصاصات المجلس النيابي
ولكن لا يقفوا امام تجميدي كل اعماله
اجراءات قبلت بترحيب البعض ورفض اخرين في
ظل ازمه سياسيه تشهدها البلاد منذ بدا
سعيد تنفيذ خطته لتصحيح مسار الثوره
ومحاربه الفساد كما يصرح مرارا وتكرارا
المعارضون لقرارات سعيد ومساره واخرها
الانتخابات التشريعيه بداوا في تصعيد
خطواتهم بالفعل شهدت العاصمه مظاهره في
الاسابيع الاخيره نظامها ما يعرف بجبهه
الخلاصه التي تضم احبابا
ابرزها النهضه الاخوانيه الحزب الدستوري
الحره والتيار الديمقراطي والحزب الجمهوري
الاتحاد العام للشغل بدا ايضا على المقلب
الاخر في توصيف الانتخابات
نحن مقدمون على انتخابات
بلا لون وبلا تعمل
جاءت
وليده دستورا لم يكن تشاركيا
كثيرون على هذه الانتخابات لادخال البلاد
في مرحله من الاستقرار السياسيه مقابل
خشيه اطراف اخرى من ان تعمق الانتخابات
التشريعيه مبكرا حاله الانقسام في الشارع
والتي تترافق مع ازمه اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
لم تشهدها تونس لسنوات
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
مقتل شقيقين فلسطينيين دهسهما مستوطن عمدا
بسيارته جنوبان نابلس
اهلا بكم جديد لقي شقيقان فلسطينيان
مسرعهما في عمليه دهس نفذها مستوطن
اسرائيلي بسيارته جنوب نابلس وفقه وكاله
الانباء الفلسطينيه واضافت وكاله بان
الشقيقين
على جانب الطريق لاصلاح احد اطارات
المركبه التي كان يستقلانها رفقه افراد من
عائلتهما عندما صدمهما المستوطن عمدا
بمركبته بصوره متعمده قبل ان يلود بالفرار
من المكان
اقرا الكونغرس الامريكي في مجلس مشروع
قرار لوقف انتاج المخدرات والاجاري بها في
سوريا وتفكيك الشبكات المرتبطه بنظام
الرئيس بشار الاسد
بنظام الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
المشروع الملزم لاداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن قدمه ديمقراطيون وجمهوريون يقول ان
التجاره بالكبتن المرتبط بنظام الاسد يشكل
تهديدا عابرا للحدود ويدور بالامن البشري
في الشرق الاوسط
اما ابرز البنود التي تتضمنها
الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه تكون بتقديم الدعم
للحلفاء من دول المنطقه الذين يتلقون
كميات كبيره من خلال عمليات تهريبها الى
السعوديه
بما فيها عقوبه قيصر لاستهداف شبكه
المخدرات التابعه لنظام السوري لكن ما هي
خريطه طريق مصانع المخدرات في سوريا ومن
يديرها الجنوب السوري والمقر الرئيسي
لتصنيع المخدرات تحت اشراف ميليشيا حزب
الله وايران والفرقه الرابعه التابعه
لنظام السوري تحولت محافظه درعا وقنيطره
الى مركز لارسال المخدرات تجاه الدول
المجاوره للحدود السوريه والخليج العربي
50 معمل للمخدرات في سوريا يقع معظمها في
مناطق نفوذ نظام الاسد وفق دراسه لمركز
جسور للدراسات
اصدرت المحكمه الجزائيه الخاضعه لسطره
الحوثي في صنعاء احكام باعدام وسجن 29
معتقلا من ابناء محافظه صعده المحكمه
الحوثيه وجهت للمعتقلين 29 من معارضيها
اتهامات باتخابر فيما تؤكد منظمات حقوقيه
ان مئات الناشطين السياسيين والاكاديميين
يتعرضون لابشع صنف التعذيب المفضي للموت
في سجون ميليش الحوثي بصنع
نوصلوا لهم
شكرا
ولا اي دوله اسلاميه
دادا انجز بعد انجاز في المغرب وفي القاره
الافريقيه وفي العرب كلهم الاول
[موسيقى]
في نهايه الشهر
الرياضيون او منظمات دوليه تحتاج على
احتمال اعدام ايران لعب كره قدم
واعتقاله ممثله شهيره
فرز الاصوات في تونس وهيئه الانتخابات
تفسر ضعف المشاركه بنظام الاقتراع وغياب
المالي السياسي
على فعاليه المونديال اليوم بمباراه بين
المنتخبين الارجنتيني والفرنسي
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]